Hey Thoughty2 here.
Facebook boasts over 2.2 billion loyal subjects
and the average social minion regularly shares
their opinions about their favourite cold
sandwich meats with their family and 300 other
people they once met in a room somewhere.
Their relationship status, snapshots of their
every day and the most intimate details of
their life, they share also.
Your Facebook timeline is a written and highly
detailed history of your life.
And as we all know, a wise man once said “If
you can describe your life on one sheet of
paper, then you need to turn a new page.”
No one actually ever said that, but I couldn’t
find a meanful quote to put here, so that
will have to do.
But just how much do Facebook and other internet
giants like Microsoft, Google, Amazon and
Apple know about you?
How many secret data points have they cherry-picked
from your tree of life and what do they do
with all those sweet, succulent data cherries?
I’ll tell you what they do, they bake them
into a delicious money pie, with a big fat
advert on top of it.
And your privacy is the metaphorical pastry,
so what can you do to stop it from crumbling
to pieces?
Let me ask you, have you ever been searching
for something on the web such as toasters,
pet food or restaurants in your area that
aren’t completely terrible and then you
open up Facebook and boom!
You see adverts for toasters, pet food and
not-crap local restaurants, or whatever other
internet goodies you may have been ogling.
It probably happens to you all the time and
you either ignore it, chalk it up as yet another
massive coincidence or you start to get all
weird and suspicious, and make a tinfoil hat
for your hamster.
And suspicious you should be because the truth
is that for a long time now, Facebook has
been stalking you around the entire web like
some kind of benevolent wealthy pedophile.
Yes Facebook attorneys, I’m aware your services
have a minimum age limit, please don’t sue
me.
Facebook has always been completely free for
its users and that’s because it’s users,
you, are what’s being sold.
There’s a well-known saying that I just
made up, “If a service is free, then you
are the product”.
You are what Facebook sells, all your lovely
data.
Facebook sells to advertisers the ability
to target their adverts and their products
to Facebook users in really specific and creepy
ways based on the data that Facebook has on
you.
Say a company comes along that makes and sells
ice cream, for a price Facebook will allow
that advertiser to advertise their delicious
ice cream to every Facebook user who is a
hetrosexual female between the ages of 30
and 50 who recently ended a long term relationship
and has also had a string of previous long
term relationships, and also happens to own
two cats and isn’t lactose intolerant.
And who also lives in Nantucket, whilst they’re
at it, just because they can.
Now, I don’t mean to stereotype, but this
kind of specificity is exactly what advertisers
are looking for and Facebook has the ability
to offer that juicy data, unlike almost any
other company on Earth.
Because Facebook knows secrets about you,
things that would make your grandma slap you
in your ruddy little face if she ever found
out.
There have been rumours spreading around the
internet recently that Facebook uses people’s
microphones on their smartphones and devices
to covertly record their conversations 24/7.
Then algorithms analyse that speech to identify
what that person may be interested in and
thus show them advertisements for it.
I know what you’re thinking, “whoah slow
down there Thoughty2, you’ll be making tinfoil
hats, scarves and gloves before the end of
this video”.
But there have been thousands of reports across
the web and even videos of people talking
about something out loud in front of their
phone, for example discussing their holiday
plans to France and then logging into Facebook
later and seeing ads for villas in France.
So what’s the deal here?
Is there any truth to this?
Is Facebook a naughty nancy, spying on us
through our phones’ microphones?
The reassuringly disappointing reality is
that the expense, resources and enormous processing
power required to record, perform vocal recognition
and run an algorithm on billions of audio
feeds 24 hours a day is, with current technology,
completely impossible, even with the resources
of all the big tech companies combined.
So the likelihood that Facebook or any other
tech giant is using your microphone to spy
on you is really, really small and ex-Facebook
employees have said that it’s just not technically
or legally possible for Facebook to do that.
But the scary truth and why I’m fairly confident
that Facebook aren’t recording us is that
they don’t need to.
Seriously, they wouldn’t actually gain much
and the potential risks are enormous.
And why wouldn’t they gain anything?
Because they can already find out everything
they need to know about you without listening
to a single conversation.
Facebook’s algorithms are so sophisticated
and their data harvesting net is so unfathomably
wide that they can already build a complete
history of your life, a comprehensive profile
of your likes, dislikes, where you’ve been,
where you’re likely to go and what you’re
likely to purchase just solely based on your
online activity.
And now you’re sat there wishing you hadn’t
shopped online for avocado slicers for 4 hours
on Sunday.
But what you might not know about Facebook’s
data harvesting net is just how wide those
greedy data fishermen spread it.
Everything you do on Facebook itself, whether
through the website or app is collected and
stored - private messages, status updates,
likes, dislikes, comments and location data.
But it doesn’t stop at the Facebook app.
What if I told you that Facebook and many
other advertising companies, follow you around
the entire internet, tracking your every website
visit, and interaction.
You know those like and share buttons you
see on 99% of websites, that no one uses ever.
And all those sites that use “Login with
Facebook”?
For a web developer to put these features
into a web page they have to make a pact with
Facebook, written in code and blood.
That they will include a line of Javascript
tracking code on their website, some refer
to it as the Facebook pixel to make it sound
all cute and innocent.
Every time a visitor loads a web page that
contains the Facebook pixel, and to be clear
that is close to every web page you visit
on a daily basis, the pixel lets Facebook
know that you’ve visited that web page.
It sends back a packet of data about yourself
and your location.
When you log into Facebook it places a file
called a cookie on your computer or mobile
device.
Most cookies go all bad and rotten and eventually
remove themselves from your computer after,
30 days or so but these cookies are baked
with whatever Plutonium-based preservative
McDonalds puts into their not-burgers, they
never expire and unless you find this not-so-delicious
radioactive cookie yourself and delete it,
it will sit on your device forever.
Now, everytime you visit a website that isn’t
Facebook, the cookie alerts the Facebook code
that is most likely in that website, in the
form of a like or share button, or Login With
Facebook integration.
The cookie contains a unique code which identifies
your Facebook account.
So the website then reports back to Facebook,
behind the scenes, it sends your IP address,
your location, the browser and device you’re
using, plus other information.
Like a delicious data bento box sent straight
to facebook, that contains bit of you.
Facebook uses all this data to build a detailed
profile about you, including all the websites
you visit, and yes, even the ones you don’t
want them to know about, you sick-o.
Using all this data Facebook can accurately
work out what you’re interested in and most
importantly, what you’re likely to spend
your money on.
This data isn’t sold, but is leased to advertisers
who wish to target their products to a very
specific audience.
Facebook’s net is wide too, they don’t
just use these data collection techniques
through the Facebook platform and developer
network, the data is also collected through
their web of other companies, such as Instagram,
Whatsapp and of course Facebook Messenger,
the three cornerstones of a moronic social
diet.
All this data is funnelled into the same algorithm
to build the most complete possible profile
on you.
Because today, now more than ever before,
knowledge is power and data is money.
So invasive is Facebook’s tracking that
they seriously annoyed the country of Belgium
and if there’s one thing you don’t want
to do, it’s makes enemies with the country
that gave the world chips, waffles and more
beers than you can shake a nun at.
In 2016 a Belgian court attempted to sue Facebook
for shadow tracking its users across the web.
The Belgian court strongly disagreed with
how Facebook secretly follows their citizens
down every dark alleyway of the internet,
wearing a long blue trench coat, wielding
those cold, reptilian Zuckerberg eyes that
say “we will take your data, you will enjoy
it”.
And they argued that Facebook doesn’t do
enough to make its users aware when and on
what sites they are being tracked and their
data is being harvested in a drag-net style
and us citizens are just defenseless little
tuna fish, flapping from one useless webpage
to the next.
It was also discovered that Facebook was also
tracking users that have never even visited
the Facebook website and don’t have an account.
Using their social sharing plugins that are
on every website worth more than a pound.
Facebook allegendly logs the IP address, the
pages they visit and other information of
website visitors, regardless if they have
a Facebook account.
Even though these users have never agreed
to a Facebook privacy policy or their Terms
and Conditions, which we’ve all read, haven’t
we.
Thus this data is being collected illegally,
according to the Belgian court.
Stoked up on delicious premium beers the Belgian
court went full on beast mode against Facebook,
saying that until Facebook changes its behaviour
and stops tracking its users around the web,
that it would have to pay a fine of 250,000
Euro a day.
But because Facebook is wealthier than Pablo
Escobar’s left thumb, according to estimated
revenue figures it takes Facebook 21 minutes
to make 250,000 Euro.
Yet it was still enough of a threat to make
Zuckerberg’s empty face have an actual expression
and he set his best lawyers on the Belgians
like some kind of high-stakes Pokemon battle.
Initially Facebook-achu won the battle on
a technical clause, but Fast forward a couple
of years, until, well now and the Belgians
hit back with a new lawsuit due to recent
changes in EU law that means any EU country
can sue any company that operates or sells
services within any other European country.
This time those Belgian beauties won, the
court deemed that by anonymously following
people around the internet and collecting
data on them that Facebook had contravened
EU privacy laws.
Facebook was ordered to destroy all the unlawfully
collected data which is about as easy as clearing
your disgusting internet history in Internet
bloody Explorer and they were ordered stop
the practice immediately or pay $100 million
in fines.
But it’s not just Facebook that knows your
prefered colour of swimwear.
For many years now Apple has been building
undercover location and ad tracking technology
right into their operating systems.
Apple uses what they call an IDFA, a unique
identifier that your iPhone sends back to
Apple every time you visit a website, download
an app or open an app.
Apple shares the IDFA data with app developers
and advertisers, so that they can better target
their ads toward you.
Oh, and all Apple devices also track your
GPS location data and build a detailed private
map of exactly where you’ve been, down to
specific addresses and businesses, concretely
winning stalker of the year award.
Google also does this, on both iOS and Android
devices you can actually see a map of exactly
where you went and the path you took on any
given date.
If you haven’t already, take a look afterwards,
it will be the creepiest thing you’ve seen
in 36 minutes.
All this covert data collecting makes one
think, should we be okay with allowing our
personal information to be harvested like
meat and sold to the highest bidder?
We all enjoy the many benefits of social networks,
apps, free email and countless other services
where we, the consumer, are the product.
But when all these tech companies are collecting
a permanent and detailed databank of your
life, a digital version of your personality,
should we be okay with that?
That’s really something for you to decide.
But when our data is the product that generates
revenue, if we didn’t allow companies to
harvest it then there would be no service.
Your great aunt Mavis will never see that
sultry selfie you posted from the toilets
of some cheap bar last Friday night, and how
utterly tragic would that be.
It’s our personal data that allows companies
like Facebook and Google to exist in today’s
world, where data is king.
But it only seems fair that we should know
when and how our data is being collected.
You’re all very aware by now of the recent
Cambridge Analytica scandal.
Our data was harvested from Facebook by data
scientists in huge quantities, without our
knowledge or direct consent and then that
data was analysed to target political attack
ads at us online and on television.
The whole thing has blown up into a scandal
so big it would make Nixon jealous.
And Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg was made
to testify in court over the whole thing,
and even worse, smile.
But what makes Cambridge Analytica so utterly
scandalous is that for every user who took
the quiz that harvested that user’s data,
it also spread into their network of friends
and harvested their data too, without their
consent.
Resulting in personal data being stolen from
87 million Facebook profiles in total.
Facebook has been on defensive ever since,
but to rub salt into their wounds they are
now under pressure from a new European Union
law that aims to change the way data is collected
for good.
It’s no coincidence that this video was
released today, the 25th May 2018, because
today a new law, several years in the making
comes into effect today across the whole of
Europe.
It’s called GDPR or General Data Protection
Regulation and it’s the biggest slap in
the face to companies that wish to anonymously
harvest our data since sliced litigation.
GDPR basically means companies like Facebook
and hundreds of thousands of others that wish
to get access to any of our data have to be
really transparent and upfront about when
and how they are getting that data and importantly
exactly what they plan to do with it.
They have to inform us in plain English too,
not legal soup.
If you do still use Facebook then you may
have noticed this popup appearing recently
upon logging in, that’s because the European
Court has forced them to do so under the GDPR.
GDPR also gives European citizens the right
to write to any company that has collected
their data and ask them to delete it permanently.
Unbelievably, up until now, this hasn’t
actually been possible with most companies.
You see, the way data storage solutions such
as SQL work means it’s so, so much easier
for the company to just tick a box that hides
your data from the public instead of actually
deleting it.
So when you deactivate or delete your Facebook
account or any other online account, it and
all the data surrounding it, still exists,
it’s just hidden, but such companies can
still access it at any time.
Unfortunately GDPR only effects European citizens
or any business based in Europe.
But hold on, the saviest of tax avoiders out
there will know that to avoid billions of
pounds of tax each year Facebook is technically
headquartered in Ireland.
Yes, they exploit a legal tax loophole called
the “Double Irish Sandwich” to avoid paying
corporation tax in all the countries they
operate in, which is basically all of the
countries.
So the totally American mega corporation Facebook
is on paper an Irish company.
So shouldn’t this mean Facebook has to abide
by the GDPR for all its users across the globe,
because technically it’s headquartered in
Europe.
Ideally yes, but instead Facebook sat in a
room in Ireland and said “Hold my Guinness
Paddy, you’re gonna love this..” then
did a massive legal magic trick effectively
excluding 1.5 Billion of their users who don’t
live in Europe from being affected by GDPR
whilst using Facebook services.
And if you want me to explain exactly how
they did that I’m going to need five more
pints of Guinness and law degree to pass that
bar.
But to put it simply Facebook have basically
said, if you don’t live in Europe, you don’t
have the right control your own personal data,
so that’s bloody sly.
At the end of the day, your data is more important
than you probably give it credit for.
When some faceless conglomerate knows your
most intimate secrets and holds more information
about you than your own mother, you should
be worried, because that gives them enormous
power over you and who knows what the future
holds.
Your personal data can be used to manipulate
you, brainwash you and sell you plastic frickin
vegetable choppers and nobody wants that.
There are lots of ways you can still use these
free online services whilst keeping a firm
grasp on your data and online security, but
one of the best ways, is to use a virtual
private network, a VPN.
That’s why I use NordVPN every time I connect
to the internet on every device I own, so
I can stay totally private online.
NordVPN have kindly sponsored this video.
Hopefully you guys know by now that I only
promote products that I truly believe in and
NordVPN is a product I believe in so strongly
that I have been using their VPN personally
every day since I discovered NordVPN over
a year ago, really.
NordVPN has an automatic kill switch, super
simple browser extensions and it even blocks
ads for you.
NordVPN uses military-grade encryption, seriously,
it actually uses the same encryption protocols
that are used by the U.S. government to secure
classified information and by the NSA to protect
national security data!
NordVPN even bypasses the great firewall of
China, it also works in Middle East where
some other VPNs fail.
NordVPN has an incredible 4,319 servers to
choose from all over the globe.
NordVPN is super fast and has no impact on
your internet speed whilst using it.
They have 24/7 customer support, they never
log any of your data because they are based
outside of the EU and the US, and that’s
really important when choosing a VPN.
You can use unlimited bandwidth and they use
double layer data encryption for total anonymity
online.
The best part - it’s incredible value for
money.
I firmly believe that every single internet
user should use a VPN, even if it’s just
for peace of mind and knowing that your data
and internet browsing activity is safe.
And there is no VPN better than NordVPN, I
can personally vouch for that.
Click the link in the description to sign
up get your NordVPN account now and secure
yourself online once and for all, you won’t
regret it.
Thanks for watching.